hey ben so i'm definitely a left-leaning
student um but i listened to your
podcast every day well thank you for
coming and thank you for listening i
appreciate it thank you thank you
uh so my question uh is about race and
culture
so while i agree with you that when you
look at white america it's silly to say
that the majority of white americans
are actively trying to prevent you from
getting to where you want to be
i'm east indian and i have definitely
experienced some racism but i never felt
as though it keeps indians from
succeeding
so i do think there's a cultural
component that supersedes the color of
your skin
but i also think that it's naive to say
that it just so happens that the same
minority groups that have been
historically oppressed
happen to have cultures that are less
conducive to success
i believe that environment can create
culture can you acknowledge the
historical reasonings that led
that these so-called unsuccessful
cultures and not put blame on these
minority groups
i know that in your heart i don't think
you're a racist person but in my
in my opinion to blame people for their
failure
for their cultural failures without
taking into consideration
uh the history in general conceals a
lack of empathy and
sort of hints at racism okay so i'll
fight back on the last point that
that you know there's anything to do
with empathy or racism here um but
i fully agree with you like 100 not not
like 90 100
i think the bad cultures are generally
the result of bad things that have
happened in the past or bad modes of
thought that have prevailed over time
so for example uh there's a great book
by thomas soule
called uh black rednecks and white
liberals uh and that book
essentially suggests that a lot of the
pa the pathologies that exist about
single motherhood for example in the
black community
or high rates of violence are actually
outgrowths of
a slave and post-slave culture that was
imposed
by a white society that didn't bother
with policing that didn't
in that didn't care about inculcating
morals or virtues
in in slaves obviously they actually
actively fought against it
because they didn't want that to happen
um and so there was an active fight from
a symbol
against assimilation by white people and
that created an underground culture
that's really bad
and that existed in parts of white
america too it exists in appalachia so
yes i think bad cultures have nothing to
do with race uh i don't think that just
because
this is why i'm saying i don't know why
it borders on racism to say that
cultures are bad like some cultures are
bad some cultures are good and that has
nothing to do with race
charles murray wrote an entire book
called coming apart about pathologies in
white communities
uh that that are really destructive so
bad cultures do arise
very often from historical circumstances
including historical discrimination
what i say is that today there's nothing
preventing an
individual from superseding the culture
in which you grew up and making good
decisions
then the free country somebody's gonna
have to break this chain somebody's
going to have to break this cycle
and so am i going to bl i don't care if
you want to if you want to
say that that the pathology that exists
in the black community uh black inner
city community of
high rates of single motherhood and
violence for example um or
lack of institutional wealth uh that
that is a result of historic racism i'm
fine with you saying that i don't have
any problem with that i'm not talking
about historical races when i talk about
white privilege i'm talking about right
now the idea that there's a
superstructure of rules and laws
that are preventing you from succeeding
or a culture that is trying to keep you
down i don't think that's the case so
the question becomes
if you are here let's say let's say that
on average the culture in white america
uh or with regard to single motherhood
to take an example
uh is is here right because there's less
single mother in the white community
than the black community
and in the black community it's it's
here because it's 70 single motherhood
rate and the white
community is 40 okay so the question is
before thanks to
racism and thanks to discrimination
there was a cap on the black community
that was here
and they couldn't get past it okay now
the ceiling's been removed so what do
you as an individual black person do
to change your life and i don't think
it's helpful and
in fact i think it's actually quite
hurtful to spend an enormous amount of
time talking about
the legacy of discrimination and racism
instead of talking about what can you do
right now to fix your problem now this
is a general issue that i have in all of
my relationships my when my wife comes
to me
and she says there's a problem in my
life before we even have the
conversation i say to her
is this a listening conversation or is
this that you want me to fix that
conversation
and i think that when it comes to
politics there should be far fewer
listening conversations like i want you
to tell me about all the crap that's
happening because i don't care
i mean i care but it doesn't but now the
question is what you're gonna do
right that's a much more important
conversation because we only have five
minutes together
is that five minutes gonna be spent on
all the terrible things that happened
which i fully agree with
that i would have fought if i were there
but i wasn't right are we gonna spend
five minutes talking about all the
terrible things that happened to blacks
and jews and gays and women and
hispanics in the united states are we
gonna talk about right now what you can
do to succeed because i don't think that
the rules are holding you back
so i've never ever at any point
suggested that there's not been historic
discrimination against black people
or even that current day poverty is at
least in part an outgrowth of that
historic discrimination what i have
suggested is that if you're using that
historic discrimination as a reason why
you are not
as an individual human being becoming
more income mobile
and not making good decisions no one is
making the call for you right now as an
individual to get that girl pregnant
and that's that's the argument that i'm
making
sure yeah um so i guess like
would you like so don't you you have to
admit though that
between different races and different
cultures there are there are different
levels of success
and there's definitely you would expect
that somebody who grows up
with with uh with less with being able
less to succeed you you would
you would expect that that would happen
in certain in certain communities and
certainly right that's why they're
called pathologies of culture yeah for
sure
i mean if you grew up in a worse
situation than somebody else who grew up
in a better situation of course you're
going to grow up
having obstacles that that other person
has to overcome but that doesn't mean
that that other person number one
victimized you
right there's no one in america today
for example who's enslaved a black
person
that i know of or if they have to be in
jail um i'm sure that nobody
in this room right none of the young
white people in this room were alive
during the times of jim crow
so the question is do we take away from
the white people in this room to rectify
historic injustices or do we recognize
that history is filled with historic
injustices
and now we're going to have to find a
way to overcome those obstacles together
without redistributing income for
example
now i have called for movements for
example for uh
for companies to go into inner cities
and make a deal with
students in inner cities and say to them
listen you get good grades and we'll pay
for your college and then you come
afterward and you work for us for three
years to pay off that debt
i think there are things that we can do
in the private sector this is why i
think religious communities are so
important
i'm not against charity i'm not against
us as individuals going out and helping
people
what i am against is the idea that the
government can fix this problem because
the government cannot fix historic
inequity
all the government can do is set the
rules at at an equal level equal law
equal you know equal judgment under law
equal justice under law
is the only way that we're ever going to
approach anything that looks like a fair
society there's no such thing as a fair
society where the government plays god
and gets them to others and takes from
others so
would you would you say that you
basically we should
like other people who are not you know
in an oppressed state they should
they should wait and wait for other
people to pull themselves up uh
do you think that's how we should solve
it or do you think there is i think
every culture in american history every
individual in american history who has
succeeded
has had a combination of people who help
them out not in the government people
who help them out
and their own capacity to bootstrap it
and when my
great-grandparents got here they were
dirt poor and didn't speak english
great great grandparents got here
they're dirt poor and didn't speak
english this is true for virtually
everybody in the room right at some
point somebody came over here and they
were dirt poor and didn't speak english
uh and that doesn't mean that on a
generational level people are gonna go
from
from zero to a hundred but it does mean
that we're gonna need to move in the
right direction as opposed to sitting
around and talking about historic
injustice all day
because that doesn't get anything done